jeune on recommandait de piloter jusque
dans
en exil ont encore besoin d' aide pour
s'orienter d'une classe à l'autre depuis
deux semaines ce nouvel élève pique la
curiosité dans les couloirs bondés de
l'école jean xxiii de dorval
en rémission de sa luccioni nadine
maltais peut maintenant suivre ses cours
tous les jours tout en restant chez elle
elle contrôle le robot à partir de son
ordinateur portable
je les vois super bien mais aussi
nigauds c'est aussi l'occasion
d'interagir avec les amis c'est sûr
qu'après ce que j'ai vécu et ce peu
pouvoir avoir une vie normale en tant
que tel c'est difficile fait ça va comme
donner une certaine
stabilité ce robot fabriqué par la
compagnie américaine vigo est à l'essai
à la commission scolaire marguerite
bourgeoys il coûte 7000 $ nos
conférences existe depuis des années
mais on n'a jamais une solution qui
offrait honte en flexibilité sur les
cinquante trois mille élèves une
quinzaine chaque année doivent être
scolarisés à la maison pour des raisons
de santé
quand j'ai vu le robot à la commission
scolaire
cegedim moi j'ai besoin d'être au point
de mes élèves qui s'en va encore en
opération et qui va pas c'est peut-être
le restant de l'année à la maison je
veux donner une réponse juste à flasher
après un automne d'absence et en
remplacement de hanche en février
nadine recevez 6 heures d'enseignement à
domicile avec le robot elle plus en plus
être en place à plein temps la radiation
se faire vraiment vous bien fait que je
reste à la maison surtout pour pouvoir
rattraper le début de l'année sa
présence virtuelle lui permet même de
faire des travaux en équipe c'est
spécial mais je pense que je suis plus
étonné
ici a nourri despatie radio canada
dorval